bonjour et bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
édition d'en quête d'europe dans cette
émission je vous emmène en pologne un
des premiers pays européens à exploiter
son gaz de schiste ensuite direction le
luxembourg où les salles de shoot existe
depuis plusieurs années
enfin terminus en grande bretagne où les
citoyens et le gouvernement britannique
lutte contre le gaspillage alimentaire
mais d'abord sandra cerqueira nous
emmène en espagne dans un village
d'irréductibles andalou qui lutte contre
la crise
sandra marinaleda c'est un petit peu le
contre exemple de la crise espagnole
pourquoi ce choix parce que c'est une
ville qui a décidé justement d'aller à
contre-courant
c'est une ville qui ne connaît pas la
crise d'une ville de 3000 habitants
située près de séville où il n'y a pas
de chômage et où le maire et populaire
donc c'est une situation qui contraste
avec ce que connaît le reste du pays et
dans le reste du pays un actif sur
quatre est au chômage le gouvernement
bat des sommets d'impopularité seulement
7 % des espagnols se disent satisfaits
de leur politique
donc là on vous suit dans le sud de
l'espagne en andalousie
vous
tout l'été ils ont marché sur les routes
d'andalousie pour dire non à la crise
derrière celui que les espagnols
surnomme robin des bois
il a pris la tête d'un mouvement de
résistance populaire
bien décidé à convaincre les maires de
ne pas obéir à la politique d'austérité
les coupes budgétaires se font sur le
dos des travailleurs
ce gouvernement de droite a fait tout le
contraire de ce qu'il a promis
c'est pourquoi il est légitime il faut
le chasser au plus vite une marche et
des opérations coup de poing dans les
supermarchés pour aider les pauvres
touchés par la crise politique a on a
bien sûr beaucoup critiqué pour tout ça
mais ça n'est pas du vol c'est un acte
d'insoumission sans violence pour
attirer l'attention et montrer qu'il
faut voir de l'autre côté de la crise
ceux qui n'ont plus rien même plus de
quoi manger il faut une rébellion
citoyenne pour mettre en place un autre
modèle économique et politique
sinon ça va être terrible
c'est le militant de la gauche
anticapitaliste qui parle
il y à 30 ans juan manuel gordillo
décide de lancer dans sa ville une
expérience des plus originales petite
commune andalouse située à une heure de
séville des noms de rues évocateur et
des fresques au slogan de révolte
pas de police municipale une sorte
d'enclavé communiste en plein coeur de
l'europe fondée sur une économie à 90%
public alors que l'andalousie et la
région espagnole la plus touchée par le
chômage avec un taux de 34 % à
marinaleda tout le monde travaille
une bonne partie des habitants est
employé par la coopérative de la ville
créée par les ouvriers agricoles eux
mêmes après des années de lutte
en 1992 ils obtiennent gain de cause et
exproprient 1200 hectares de terre la
terre doit être à ceux qui la
travaillent dans le pays ça va mal et
nous on a la chance de ne pas connaître
le chômage
notre exemple montre qu'on est une
solution viable face aux marchés quel
que soit leur poste à responsabilité ou
nous tous reçoivent la même chose 47
euros par jour et effectue une rotation
afin d'assurer un revenu à tous
l'objectif de la coopérative
ce n'est pas de s'enrichir c'est de
donner du travail et ça on ne le voit
pratiquement nulle part les autres ils
veulent gagner toujours plus d'argent
mécanisée pour qu'il y ait le moins de
main d'oeuvre est ici ce n'est pas ça le
but mais avec la crise ils sont de plus
en plus nombreux à venir postuler pour
travailler dans les champs
difficile de donner du travail à tout le
monde parmi les chômeurs qui arrivent
beaucoup était dans le bâtiment au
moment où l'espagne est en proie au boom
de l'immobilier marinaleda décide
d'aller à contre-courant en favorisant
l'autoconstruction il est possible d'y
louer une maison de 90 m² pour 15 euros
par mois
il faut absolument que chacun aide à la
construction de son logement et à celui
de ses voisins on est 18 dans la rue on
s'entraide et si on ne peut pas le faire
on fait appel à quelqu'un d'autre de la
salle où c'est la commune qui propose
les terrains et fournit le matériel
nécessaire à la construction des
logements on est subventionnée on
rembourse en payant un peu chaque mois
sera propriétaire que dans 60 ou 70 ans
c'est une façon d'éviter la vente et
donc la spéculation
de même il est impossible côté quai car
on ne fait pas appel aux banques pour un
crédit
lusine de la coopérative où les récoltes
sont mise en conserve appartient aussi à
ceux qui travaillent les moyens sont
collectiviser et les prises de décisions
aussi les habitants participent à des
assemblées publiques et décident
ensemble de ce à quoi est destiné le
budget de la ville
de cette façon on est sûr que les
décisions sont bonnes pour tout le monde
ça n'a pas l'air comme ça mais on doit
lutter parfois durement pour imposer ce
système municipal
beaucoup de politiques pourrait suivre
notre exemple mais ça ne les intéresse
pas que tout le monde puisse vivre
dignement menace procès à droite comme à
gauche on critique un système qui sans
les aides publiques de la communauté
autonome d'andalousie ne serait pas
viable
d'autres dénoncent le populisme d'un
homme réélu régulièrement depuis 30 ans
qui chaque samedi et en direct pendant
une heure sur la télé locale de la ville
située juste à côté de la mairie
sandra on le voit bien dans votre
reportage à l'heure où l'espagne est
dans une situation économique critique
les actions et la politique de ce maire
est extrêmement populaire
oui il incarne le rejet de l'austérité
et son action trouve un écho important
dans la société espagnole
il est très très médiatisé bon il a été
très critiqué par les politiques mais il
est très médiatisée et très populaire
chez les espagnols eux mêmes dans la rue
il est arrêté sollicités donc on voit en
espagne de plus en plus d'actes de
désobéissance civile et les présidents
de région notamment qui refusent
d'appliquer les coupes budgétaires dans
la santé dans l'éducation des couples
qui sont demandés par le gouvernement
central et comment réagit la population
face à cette austérité
on voit de plus en plus les espagnols la
société civile et sa touche vraiment
tous les échelons de la société
les espagnols qui s'organise pour
contrer les effets de l'austérité
il ya beaucoup de personnes dans le
besoin qui occupent des bâtiments privés
laissé à l'abandon
beaucoup de manifestations pour dénoncer
aussi les expulsions il y en a
ya eu 50 milles dans le pays des
expulsions qui peuvent conduire à des
suicides oui d'ailleurs le gouvernement
a décidé d'un moratoire face à ces
manifestations d'un moratoire de deux
ans sur les expulsions pour les
personnes les plus démunies
oui on voit aussi des médecins et des
infirmières qui décide de ne pas
appliquer les lois ces dérives refuse de
ne plus soigner les immigrés sans
papiers comme le demande une loi récente
qui vise à faire des économies
donc en fait ce sont autant d'actes de
désobéissance civile des actes un peu
citoyens qui sont des alternatives à
cette crise qui asphyxient aujourd'hui
l'espagne merci sandra en ces temps de
crise un pays a décidé d'exploiter ces
gaz de schiste pour relancer son
économie
un virage énergétique controversé
direction la pologne avec paul bouffard
alors paul à l'image des états unis et
de la ruée vers l'or en pologne c'est un
peu la ruée sur le gaz de schiste est ce
que c'est un nouvel eldorado
eh bien oui il s'agit bien d'un nouvel
eldorado pour la pologne le gouvernement
polonais justement s'est précipitée fait
des études américaines ont révélé des
ressources importantes dans le sous sol
polonais on a évoqué trois cents ans
d'exploitation à peu près enfin revu à
la baisse aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on parle justement de 60 ans
environ là en ce moment on en est encore
au stade de l'exploration et avant une
extraction effective et il faudra
attendre une dizaine d'années donc là on
vous suit au nord de varsovie
tarder à cette eau minérale a beaucoup
de vertus curatives
elle est utilisée depuis des siècles
pour guérir de nombreux maux est en
danger à cause des forages effectués
dans la région pour trouver du gaz de
schiste
roberts ne se prive pas de goûter l'eau
de son village une eau minérale réputé
en pologne
et pourtant la source est en sursis à
cause de l'exploitation du gaz de
schiste
d'ici quelques mois dans la région des
forages devraient voir le jour un drame
pour robert son projet de rénover les
termes tomberait à l'eau
personne n'investira si des forages pour
extraire le gaz de schiste se font dans
un rayon de 10 km il y aura danger de
pollution pour les eaux salines le gaz
de schiste son exploitation nécessite
une fracturation hydraulique
les compagnies gazières injecte sous
pression un grand volume d'eau mêlées à
des produits chimiques dans la terre
laroche explose et libère le gaz
prisonnier les résidus d'eau peuvent
contaminer les nappes phréatiques
voisine et pour l'état polonais
impossible de passer à côté de cette
nouvelle source d'énergie
le gouvernement défend son nouvel
eldorado le gaz de schiste
c'est une chance pour la pologne mais
aussi pour l'union européenne
cette forme d'énergie peut jouer un rôle
important pour la relance de l'économie
polonaise mais aussi rendre la pologne
indépendante vis-à-vis des étrangers
le gouvernement espère profiter des
réserves importantes du pays pour
alimenter en gaz sa population pendant
plusieurs dizaines d'années sans avoir
besoin de son voisin russe jusqu'en 2022
la pologne est lié par contrat avec le
géant russe de l'énergie gazprom qui
leur fournit près de la moitié de leur
consommation gazière
le gaz de schiste pourrait inverser la
tendance nous considérons avec beaucoup
de rigueur les angoisses des populations
et nous voulons lutter contre les mythes
liés au gaz de schiste
par exemple mon ministre le ministre du
trésor a bu en direct à la télévision
nationale
le liquide que l'on injecte pour la
fracturation pour prouver que ce n'est
pas du poison bartoli compte investir
plus de 12 milliards d'euros dans
l'exploitation de ce gaz de schiste
alors on ouvre les portes à tous les
investisseurs et dans les campagnes
polonaise on installe les forages comme
ici à gare vos lignes à deux heures de
route de la capitale selon la compagnie
polonaise d'énergie hors laine qui n'a
pas souhaité nous ouvrir officiellement
les portes du site
il n'y a aucun danger les rejets
polluants passeront dans un système
d'épuration heureux et ce n'est pas la
vie de cet homme
marek pida à la tête de l'ol j'ai
polonaise hinse pro il dénonce cette
exploitation du sol
selon lui le gouvernement a trop vite
oublier l'impact écologique
il y aura des centaines puis des
milliers de forage comme celui ci
car pour le gaz de schiste on a besoin
de beaucoup plus de forages que dans le
cas du gaz naturel et pour les habitants
qui sont dans le voisinage pour le
tourisme pour l'eau c'est un véritable
danger
alors il ya du gaz le forage va
s'installer
pas de commentaire
c'est intéressant ça vous n'avez rien
trouvé donc la gare ballin marek
rencontre les voisins du forage et chez
les agriculteurs l'inquiétude monte
qu'allez vous faire si les exploite près
de vauchamps l'eau a déjà sa liste
c'est vrai elle est comment brunâtre
brunâtre alors vous la buvée nombreux
lots municipal le puits il est condamné
c'est inutile là les brûlots le piquant
depuis qu'ils ont commencé à forer je
sais pas ce que nous allons devenir
relancer l'économie se défaire de la
main russe selon un sondage 73 % des
polonais disent oui au gaz de schiste et
pour s'assurer le succès le gouvernement
distribue les permis d'exploitation pour
quelques dizaines de milliers de dollars
y compris sur des sites naturels
protégés
aucune règle n'encadre l'installation de
forage sur le sol polonais vole on le
voit bien dans votre reportage le gaz de
schiste semble être une aubaine pour
l'économie polonaise c'est exactement ça
en fait varsovie voit dans ce gaz de
schiste une opportunité formidable
d'abord le gaz de schiste médine pologne
ça permettrait de développer certaines
régions des routes des infrastructures
des industries ensuite même si ce gaz de
schiste et à ces polluants ils rejettent
dans l'air du méthane par exemple ça
permettrait aux polonais d'améliorer
leur bilan carbone
parce qu'en pologne l'électricité est
principalement produite à partir du
charbon encore aujourd'hui il ya une
chose qu'on ressent bien sûr le sur le
terrain c'est que le gouvernement
souhaite s'affranchir de la dépendance
énergétique vis-à-vis de la russie via
gasprom exactement le voisin russe
fournit une grande part des ressources
gazières de la pologne
et depuis la guerre froide les relations
entre ces deux pays sont assez tendus et
à ce jour donc la pologne cherche
peut-être à s'émanciper
son grand frère russe et surtout en
matière énergétique
mais paul ce qu'on voit aussi dans votre
reportage c'est que même si la
contestation existent elles restent
quand même embryonnaire comment vous
expliquez l'adhésion des polonais à ce
projet d'exploitation du gaz de schiste
a en fait le débat en pologne s'est pas
installé comme ici en france d'abord il
n'ya pas de loi qui cadrent
l'exploitation du gaz de schiste
ensuite le gouvernement a vraiment pas
voulu louper le coche dans les médias on
en parle très peu
on veut pas faire peur à la population
alors quand on en parle c'est quasiment
des pages entières dans le dans le
journal c'est pour faire de la
propagande le jour où je tournais
hachiko cheney qui avait bien dans la
gazeta wyborcza
une fois sur ces images exactement une
page entière à la gloire du gaz de
schiste avec des titres comme n'était
n'y ont pas la flamme
deuxième chose en pologne les
écologistes ne sont pas très actif il
représente pas vraiment une force
politique avec la contestation elle
vient plutôt des citoyens comme hachiko
tchèque
on vend de l'eau de source qui est très
bonne pour les sportifs après l'effort
ça permet de récupérer plus vite et on a
pu voir dans le reportage roberts qui
exploite cette source
et en fait lui qui possède ces termes en
début d'heure voit là exactement et lui
la peur de la pollution des rejets
polluants de ce gaz de schiste raison
pour laquelle ils s'engagent tout
simplement merci paul direction
maintenant le luxembourg à l'heure où
les polémiques sur les salles de shoot
se suivent et se ressemblent nous avons
voulu savoir comment ces établissements
fonctionnent au quotidien jérôme rabier
s'y est rendu
jérôme combien il y a deux salles de
shoot en europe alors les salles de
consommation de drogues supervisée qu'on
appelle couramment celle de shoot existe
déjà dans sept pays européens en suisse
en espagne en allemagne au danemark en
norvège aux pays-bas et donc au
luxembourg où nous nous sommes rendus
cela représente 80 salles de
consommation en europe
sur les 90 qui existent dans le monde
donc très clairement on voit que
l'europe est précurseur dans ce domaine
et pourquoi vous avez choisi d'aller au
luxembourg alors la seule structure du
pays est ouverte depuis 2005 elle est
gérée par une association le comité
national de défense sociale et il est
intéressant de noter que contrairement
en france où droite et gauche s'opposent
sur la question à luxembourg la capitale
du pays
c'est une municipalité de droite allié
avec les verts qui a installé la
structure en 2005 dépassant ainsi les
clivages traditionnels sur la question
donc on vous suit à luxembourg coincé
entre une entrée d'autoroute et les
voies de chemin de fer c'est ici dans
ces préfabriqués que les toxicomanes
viennent trouver un refuge un abri un
lieu pour se droguer installé en 2005 à
quelques centaines de mètres de la gare
c'est l'unique salle de consommation du
pays
à l'intérieur une équipe d'éducateurs et
du personnel médical accueille les
usagers
cent vingt par jour en moyenne on ne
fournit que le matériel nécessaire à la
prise de drogue
le produit en grande majorité de
l'héroïne est apportée par le client il
a ensuite vingt minutes pour le
consommer et la structure ne désemplit
pas ils sont près de mille deux cents
toxicomanes à y être inscrits pour y
accéder il faut signer un contrat où
l'on accepte les règles du lieu pas de
deal pas de bagarre et le respect pour
le personnel comme pour les locaux
philippe est un usager régulier
rien que dans cette matinée cet accro à
l'héroïne depuis 25 ans passera trois
fois dans la salle de consommation
l'héroïne je la fum donc droit qu'il kim
assure une sécurité
j'ai pas besoin de le faire chez une
personne qui va stocker que ce soit ici
ou ailleurs elle le fera c'est pas parce
que c'est un endroit où tous les
toxicomanes se rencontrent que ça va
accentuer encore plus les problèmes au
contraire si le lieu est médiatisé pour
sa salle de shoot c'est une structure
plus large qui est proposé doté d'un
budget annuel de plus de 2 millions
d'euros
on y vient aussi pour juste prendre un
café échangé ses seringues usagées
trouver de l'aide pour ses démarches
administratives 42 lits sont aussi
disponibles la nuit pour héberger les
toxicomanes sans abri le centre sur un
taux et la prise en charge simplement
leur donner
ils peuvent consommer comme ils veulent
beaucoup de gens
on remplit avec la famille ont rompu
avec la société parfois et il est
important je pense plus loin et de
garder le contact avec les personnes
très vulnérables souvent malades qui ont
besoin des aides et qu'on peut pas
laisser dans la rue monté il ya sept ans
la structure s'est pérennisée à l'époque
dans ce quartier habitué aux toxicomanes
les riverains étaient réticents
le temps a finalement permis
l'acceptation du projet si consommer de
morts devant une école primaire où ils s
on a tous voila je ne sais pas s'ils le
font toujours mais des instituteurs ils
venaient plus tôt pour faire le tour
pour ramasser des seringues abandonnées
au niveau du quartier c'est sa tête
comme on tue résistance oui bien sûr il
ya toujours beaucoup de gens qui sont
résistants qui préfère que ce soit un
quartier à côté
car derrière l'objectif sanitaire c'est
aussi la question de la sécurité qui est
en jeu ouvert 6 jours sur 7
le centre permet de maintenir la
population toxicomane à distance
respectable du centre-ville un objectif
assumé par la mairie en effet que c'est
une sécurité et pour la population de la
ville de luxembourg qui a tort ou à
raison à ce sentiment d'insécurité par
rapport aux personnes toxicomanes mais
c'est aussi une sécurité pour les
personnes concernées
bien entendu il y a dix qui se fait tout
autour nous le savons nous ne pouvons
pas l'éviter
on pourrait peut-être dire donc on peut
mieux le contrôler puisqu'elle les a
cédées limitée dans les sports oms et
ans d'existence les résultats en matière
de santé publique sont là le nombre
d'overdoses a été divisé par quatre et
les contaminations sont en chute libre
jérôme on le voit bien dans votre
reportage la structure semble pérenne
pour autant elle est toujours dans des
préfabriqués ce qu'il ya un risque
qu'elle soit fermée d'un moment à
l'autre
clairement il n'y a pas de volonté
politique de fermer la structure bien au
contraire puisque la municipalité veut
installer un bâtiment en dur de manière
définitive
alors une entreprise bloc le projet car
elle ne veut pas voir s'installer une un
tel bâtiment face à son siège social
elle engage donc tous les recours en
justice pour bloquer ça montre qu'il ya
encore une forte résistance
en attendant la municipalité a fait
ériger ces préfabriqués de manière
temporaire
mais gilles rolle le directeur du cnds
qui gère la structure et qu'on a vu dans
le reportage a l'habitude du provisoire
qui dure mais selon vous est ce qu'on
peut parler d'un bilan positif pour
cette structure alors du point de vue
sanitaire clairement oui il y a moins de
contamination au vih et aux hépatites
qui touche le milieu toxicomane
en revanche ça ne règle pas tout il ya
par exemple pas moins de consommateurs
ni moins de consommation de drogues
dures au luxembourg depuis que la
structure a ouverte
il faut prendre le centre pour ce qu'il
est un lieu d'accueil pour les
toxicomanes où ils peuvent se droguer en
sécurité d'ailleurs il n'y a jamais eu
de heurts
nortel au sein de la structure depuis
son ouverture grâce à l'intervention du
personnel médical en cas de souci merci
jérôme mercier n'aura en europe tandis
que les plus démunis affluent dans les
centres des d'alimentaire incapable de
répondre à la demande
nous continuons de jeter 179 kg par an
et par personne de nourriture à la
poubelle une réalité dans les pouvoirs
publics se sont emparés flora sauvage
s'est rendu à londres
flora en europe tous les pays sont
concernés par le gaspillage alimentaire
alors pourquoi la grande bretagne
la grande bretagne était le mauvais
élève en europe une étude publiée en
2009 a révélé qu'un quart des aliments
achetés par les consommateurs
britanniques étaient jetés directement à
la poubelle
si bien que le gouvernement a décidé de
prendre les choses en main et
aujourd'hui la grande bretagne est
l'exemple à suivre
donc là on vous suit à londres chaque
année en grande bretagne 15 millions de
tonnes de nourriture sont jetés à la
poubelle la moitié provient des ménages
steve essai de gaspiller le moins
possible et malgré tout il lui arrive de
gâcher de la nourriture
parfois c'est difficile de s'y retrouver
cette salade par exemple va peut-être
finir à la poubelle ou on compose on
congèle le pain pour faire des toasts
parce que c'est difficile de s'y
retrouver sinon
depuis quatre ans la mairie
d'arrondissement de steve a mis à sa
disposition une poubelle destinée à
recueillir ses déchets alimentaires
voici mes poubelles
jean ligne pour les déchets une autre
pour le recyclage et une autre pour la
nourriture la mairie là nous à notre
disposition gratuitement
je peux y mettre tous les déchets
alimentaires légumes fruits viandes
poissons tout y passe l'objectif du
gouvernement britannique est de réduire
le gaspillage alimentaire de 700 mille
tonnes d'ici 2015 car il ya urgence
il y a eu un réel effort au royaume uni
pour réduire le gaspillage alimentaire
on a à peu près la même population qu'en
france nous sommes 63 millions mais le
royaume uni est beaucoup plus petit en
superficie
particulièrement à londres où l'on et 8
millions donc il faut vraiment qu'on
fasse attention car on n'a pas assez de
place pour incinérer nos déchets
tristram stuart est un fervent militant
contre le gaspillage alimentaire
il organise dans les capitales
européennes des buffets gratuits avec
des ingrédients destinés à être jetés
pour mobiliser les consommateurs sur le
gaspi les consommateurs britanniques
jette environ 20 pour cent de la
nourriture qu'ils achèvent là bas
toutefois un certain nombre
d'initiatives ont été mises en place
pour réduire le gaspillage dans les
foyers des ans l'industrie ainsi d'une
réduction de 13% du gaspillage des
ménages ce qui est plutôt positif
maintenant on met la pression sur
l'industrie car les supermarchés
britanniques produisent trois cent mille
tonnes de déchets alimentaires par an
certains ont pris le problème à bras le
corps et font la chasse au gaspi les
offres promotionnelles sur les produits
qui approche de la date de péremption
ont permis à la chaîne de supermarchés
marks and spencer de réduire son
gaspillage alimentaire de 40% plus
depuis qu'ils ont mis en place cette
initiative en 2008 d'après tristram
stuart un tiers de la production
alimentaire mondiale est jeté à la
poubelle alors même qu'un milliard
d'êtres humains sur la planète ne mange
pas à sa faim à spitalfields le plus
vieux marché londonien
neuf restaurants gaspille chaque année
200 mille tonnes de nourriture
face à ce constat andres felipe ramirez
a été engagé par le centre commercial
pour limiter ce gaspillage
voici l'arrière des restaurants sex is
il y à différentes sections on a des
poubelles exploit pour la nourriture
mais livre ait la carie ici c'est la
salade le potentiel du recyclage de la
nourriture est énorme
on peut produire de l'engrais ou
d'électricité en russie quand la
nourriture qu'on jette et on empêche au
passage que ces déchets des effets
toxiques sur l'environnement
dans cette usine du sud de londres
on recycle les déchets alimentaires pour
produire de l'engrais destinés aux
agriculteurs de la région
salade poisson pain de mie les echets
collectés ici viennent des restaurants
des supermarchés ou encore des maisons
des alentours
ces céréales ne sont pas périmés mais
elles ont été jetés à la poubelle
c'est tout à fait mangeable ce produit
se périment l'année prochaine mais il ya
peut-être un problème de bactéries
l'expliquerai que c'est serré a coûté
paix je t'ai bien tout simplement
peut-être y at-il un dessin au niveau de
l'emballage et le fabricant a préféré
tout jeter plutôt que le consommateur
achète un produit avec un emballage un
peuple depuis 2002 en grande bretagne la
directive de l'union européenne sur la
mise en décharge des déchets fixe des
objectifs de recyclage et de
valorisation
dès lors une réelle prise de conscience
a eu lieu notre moteur principal c'est
la directive européenne sur les déchets
malheureusement organisé loin
d'approcher les objectifs que la
directive nous impose
on risque donc d'avoir une amende de
l'union européenne si on ne parvient pas
à réaliser ses objectifs et les denrées
alimentaires sont l'une des choses les
plus faciles à recycler
près de la moitié des aliments encore
sains sont gaspillées chaque année par
les ménages et les supermarchés de
l'union européenne alors que 79 millions
d'européens vivant en dessous du seuil
de pauvreté
l'objectif de l'union européenne est de
réduire son gaspillage alimentaire de
50% d'ici à 2025
florent le voit bien dans votre
reportage on jette de tous mais qui sont
les responsables et pourquoi
en fait on est tous responsables les
familles jette l'industrie
agroalimentaire les supermarchés les
cantines des écoles les hôpitaux tous à
notre niveau on jette de la nourriture
parfois même sans s'en rendre compte
d'après une étude de la commission
européenne le gaspillage alimentaire
représente 89 millions de tonnes soit
179 kg par an par habitant ce qui est un
chiffre considérable si on continue sur
cette lancée
ce gaspillage alimentaires devraient
augmenter de 40% d'ici à 2020
qu'est-ce qu'on jette on jette de tout
on jette des fruits des légumes de la
salade du pain des boissons à eux seuls
ces aliments représentent les deux tiers
de ce qu'on jette à la poubelle
la grande bretagne s'est attelée aux
problèmes qu en est il du reste de
l'europe et de la france en particulier
alors chaque français jette en moyenne
20 à 30 kg de nourriture par an un
chiffre que le gouvernement aimerait
bien réduire de moitié d'ici à 2025 et
dans un contexte de crise l'idée ce
serait de récupérer les invendus des
supermarchés pour les donner aux banques
alimentaires donc on ferait d'une pierre
deux coups on réduire est le gaspillage
alimentaire et on aiderait les
associations d aide aux plus démunis
merci flora voilà c'est la fin de cette
émission rendez vous travaillez sur
public sénat et tous les jours sur
publicsenat.fr